تعاهدت المفوضيه الاوروبيه بتقديم بيئه
وخمسين مليون يورو لتونس منها 100 مليون
بهدف في اداره الحدود من اجل مكافحه
للتجار بالبشر بما كان ذلك خبر حلقتنا
ونناقشه في مسارات ثلاثه في اي سياق جاءت
زياره الوفد الاوروبيه رفيع المستوى الى
تونس وما الدور الذي ينتظره الاوروبيون من
تونس في موضوع مكافحه تدفق اللاجئين وما
مدى استعداد تونس لقبول القمر ما هي
الافاق المحتمله للتعاون بين السلطات
التونسيه والجانب الاوروبي
[موسيقى]
هناك تكادف دوله كبير ولا يحوم حول تونس
وسؤال المطروح في هذا السياق ما هي ادوات
على هذا التكاتف الدولي الذي لا علاقه له
اطلاقا بموضوع صندوق النقد الدولي يعني
المساله اكبر من كل هذا المساله هي مساله
اعاده موقع اعاده تستقطاب تونس لازاله
الثليج الذي بدا عليه الامر خلال شهرين
الاخيرين او ثلاثه اشهر بينه وبين الاتحاد
الاوروبي العلاقات شمال شمال هي
في اتعس مراحيلها الان علاقات جنوب جنوب
باعتبار تتذكرون جيدا العلاقات كانت
علاقات شارك خمسه زائد خمسه بين الدول
الاوروبيه وبين دول شمال افريقيا
وكانت هذه العلاقات في ادنى مستوياتها في
سنتين او ثلاث سنوات الاخيره تقدم السياق
العام يمكن ان نعدل ملامحه وخصائصه ولكن
العنوان الاكبر والابرز في المساء التي
تقوم بها السيد جورج ملوني عرابه التقارب
التونسي الاوروبي
العناوين البارزه واساسا عنوان كبيران هي
قضيه الهجره غير النظاميه والامر الثاني
ايضا الصعوبات الاقتصاديه وتقريب النظر
بين السلطات التونسيه وصندوق النقد الدولي
كممضي الان بحزمه وعود رغم انه التسريبات
شحيحه ولكن يمكن ان نقول ان هناك تم اذابه
الجديد اولا مع
يبدو الان ان نذهب اكثر فاكثر الى كما قلت
تدوير الزوايا وايجاد قاعده تفاوض مع
الاتحاد الاوروبي
ان ايطاليا وبقيه البلدان الاوروبيه تزداد
قلقا بسبب الاوضاع في تونسيا وبالطبع
الامر الامر له علاقه
بالهجره غير الشرعيه نعم صحيح انه في
اوروبا وفي ايطاليا لدينا بوعث قلق ازاء
بعض القرارات التي اتخذها الرئيس قيس سعيد
والاجراءات التي قام بها والتي لا تتماشى
مع معاييرنا
للديمقراطيه لكن اعتقد ان المشكله سيتم
حلها لان هناك رغبه متبادله
المساعده الماليه الاوروبيه
لتونس مهمه ويمكن ان تمهد
لدور لصندوق النقد الدولي وبعد لقاءات
الاحد نامل
مفاوضات مع صندوق النقد الدولي وتنتهي الى
النجاح والوضع سيستقر في تونس
وسيجعل من تونس في موقف افضل للسيطره على
الهجره غير الشرعيه غير النظاميه
الهجره الجماعيه
وذلك تحت
توطين هؤلاء في تونس بمقابل وهو الامر
الذي رفضه رئيس الجمهوريه التونسيه مجعل
تونس بمثابه الحارس وقال بصريح العماره
قال تونس اصبحت كل طرق تؤدي الى تونس وليس
كل طرق الامر
الثاني
قليله جدا 50 مليون اورو تقريبا نفس
المبلغ الذي دفع للمغرب منذ 54 يعني مثلا
ليس اموال المثل هي تقارب هي ازاله الجليد
[موسيقى]
تونس منذ سنوات حتى منذ يعني سلطه
السابق بن علي حنا اذن انخرطت في هذا في
هذا الجهد ولكن اعتقد في السنوات الاخيره
ربما ربما وجدت تونس اولا عاجزه تماما
نظرا للصعوبات والماليه عن مكافحه الهجره
غير الشرعيه لاس واسباب اللوجستيه اي عجز
الماليه العموميه عن توفير الامكانيات
اللازمه سواء كانت يعني بواخر او سكنت
يعني اكبر سواحل الى الى غير ذلك تدريب
تدريب القوات الامنيه البحريه يعني
الاستكشاف الاستعلام تبادل المعطيات كل
هذه المسائل اللوجستيه تونس عاجزه عنها
تماما لاسباب ماديه ولذلك ولذلك تامل تونس
تماما ان
امكانيه الماديه عن من خلال التعاون مع
الاتحاد الاوروبي من اجل تحديث الاسطول
لمكافحه الهجره غير شرعيه في ايجاد
قواعد مثل للتعاون التونسي الايطالي من
خلال مشاريع او من خلال الكوتا لم تبين
السلطات الايطاليه اي بائخه امل في ان
يمكن يعني الاستثمار الاستثمار الاقتصادي
العميق التطور على المدى الطويل من اجل
كما قلت تخفيف حده الهجره تونس تريد ان
تقول اذا ما اردتم ان ابذل جهد فعليكم ان
تمولوا
الاقتصاد التونسي وتحديد
بسبب ما ظهر من صعوبات مع صندوق النقد
الذهبي في العلاقات مع الاوروبيين وغيرهم
هناك محاوله
لحلها طبعا نحن نريد سويه ان نسيطر على
تدفق المهاجرين هذا من مصلحتنا لان تونس
قريبه منا جغرافيا وهي مهمه ايضا لتدعيم
استقرار تونس بحد ذاتها